we want to talk about families and
ethics
i don't want to do that i mean his
family we could talk about all night his
family's
my family my family just a fortune
coming down and helping us with
government
all right joining us now to respond
president trump's uh son donald trump jr
you know we we're both you know we're
testing this we've been tested and i
don't want to get you know
they'll throw us on the gulag uh yeah
but where's my mouth
um all right so you're sitting in here
i'm watching it look i understand i i
grew up
i played hockey we dropped the gloves
every day
um some people probably think it's too
hot yeah
it's it's but it was both sides yep um
but at the end of the day i look at your
dad and my take is
well if he didn't fight back against the
deep state if he didn't fight for the
money for the wall
if china and japan and and mexico
and our western european allies and
canada didn't believe
that he meant it on trade deals they
wouldn't have happened what about peace
in the middle east sean
uh that happened not because of people
like joe biden who've been in government
for 47 years but because donald trump
took a different approach and when he
said he's going to do something
they believed him so you know it was
obviously combative but i think you also
have to look and the american people
have to understand
you know what donald trump has been
through impeachment hoax
russia collusion nonsense there's actual
russia collusion now that literally
wire transfers from a known associate of
vladimir putin
there's a first lady of moscow she
happens to be a billionaire but guess
what you don't become a billionaire
first lady of moscow
uh without connections to vladimir putin
now it's there
for four years i get to hear about me uh
you know that's something they were
hoping that i did a fraction of what
hunter did i'd be in jail right now you
had so many
and you spent three years of your life
now paid for by the dnc
acknowledged the fbi was working with a
known
russian agent you know a known spy and
it's like oh now we don't want to hear
anything about it so
you know if there's a combative nature
where you come out hot of the box
you know it's because he's had to deal
with it he's have to watch his family be
subjected to it he had to be subjected
to himself and by the way more
importantly he still delivered for the
american people because that was the
reality
joe biden couldn't answer what he's done
for 47 years joe biden talks about race
that's wonderful what did he do about it
nothing you talked about what he did you
talked about his statements his comments
donald trump is the guy that got
president reform done alice johnson was
one of our guests tonight
she flew over here with us today one of
the first people don jr criminal justice
reform
he got opportunity zones historically
black colleges
police reform record low unemployment
african-americans hispanic americans
asian americans women in the workplace
youth unemployment
and i thought one of the most powerful
lines of the night too is on covet
joe if he would have listened to you
you're afraid you're calling the travel
man
ten days after the first case of corona
100 it was racist i mean at what point
in time was
was it racist to shut down travel from
the epicenter of a deadly viral outbreak
any other place that i've ever known
shown that would be called common sense
but joe can't get out of the way of the
woke mob he has to try to appease them
it's why he couldn't do anything about
police officers
it's why he couldn't in the dnc and no
democrat said anything about the
violence going on in these cities
because
they don't want to upset their base and
that's really problematic how does it go
over with him
actually denying the the biden bernie
bolshevik bernie manifesto which he
agreed to
well beyond that i mean they talk about
the green new deal you know they'll say
you know
well it was 93 trillion dollars not the
100 trillion dollars that my father had
said
i mean that's the reality that's how
these things will be fan checked they'll
say
well trump wasn't strong enough on white
supremacy i mean he denounced
denounced everything first of all right
there more importantly he literally for
the first american president
made the kkk a domestic terrorist
organization
last week so you know they will spin
that but they will neglect
the facts and that's the point if i did
what hunter did i'd be in jail but
that's not a fact
if our fbi did this to an incoming
president barack obama or an incoming
joe biden
it would be the biggest scandal in
american political history when it
happens to trump
that's okay because we don't like trump
we don't want someone who's actually
going to be effective we don't want
someone who's actually going to take us
out of these wars these endless wars
the things that joe biden would push us
for you know tax policy that is asinine
joe biden made the tax policy they want
to give donald trump a hard time for
playing by their rules
it's ridiculous i always said that
america
knew what they were electing in your dad
in 2016. that is an iconoclast
somebody that is not part of the swamp
uh somebody
that is there to break down the system
this is what draining the swamp looks
like and it's not pretty
is it uh it's not and the swamp has
teeth as we found out i mean look at
what they've tried to do to him
throughout look at all the lies you know
everyone's running with anonymous
sources i've seen more anonymous store
stuff that falls and gets debunked
after they get one week to run with the
story as though it's the gospel
uh you know that's the real problem and
so you know if there is a frustration
where my father then comes out and comes
out aggressively
it's because they've been doing this for
four years they talk about a peaceful
transition
of power the american republic has
existed for 243 years
obama and biden were the first people to
not have a
peaceful transition of power they tried
to weaponize
their friends in government and the
highest levels of american law
enforcement
to try to combat this president the duly
elected president of the united states
they're playing games with ballots all
over the place you saw pennsylvania you
saw the o'keeffe stuff
you know and we're supposed to pretend
like it doesn't happen because the
democrats control the media so they
won't highlight very obvious things just
like again
they're not going to highlight hunter's
connection to xi and china
governmental investment they're not
going to talk about him being tied to
money
to putin and human trafficking and
prostitution rings
that's off limits it's the kind of stuff
if i did it if i did a fraction of it
it would be the biggest scandal it would
be the biggest story for weeks
it would single-handedly disqualify my
fungus from being there because the
media would say at 100
it's like no big deal it's not really a
problem it's okay for him you know
things evolve in a country things evolve
in you know we supposedly celebrate free
speech in this country
um why would i be very interested in
put the two candidates on the stage for
two hours
and let them go at it i let them take it
on
i think it'd be great listen we've seen
that we knew that was coming anyway with
across wallace you know i understand
he's a fox guy but he's
he's no uh he's no conservative he's
gonna be and he's no
centrist either uh you know that's sort
of the nature of this game and i think
that's the way
you know why my father has to play it
that way he's got to combat that because
he's not just fighting conservative
ideas versus liberal ideas i mean he's
taking on a main a multi-billion dollar
mainstream media complex
joe biden can hide in the basement he
doesn't have to get out and do campaign
rallies
the media will do that for him he can
sit there for months and do a debate
prep because no one's going to ask him a
question as to why he's not taking any
questions how do you get away with not
answering
whether you're stacked to court or not
because you know what the answer is
he knows what the answer is so he
doesn't want to lie now for when he
eventually does it but it's no secret
you say oh amy comey but she's the
reason they're now talking about this
they were talking about this two months
ago before ruth bader ginsburg passed
away
you know and donald trump was right ruth
bader ginsburg said the president is the
president for four years not a fraction
of that not three years
she's he's the president for four years
by biden because he's like well
you have to have an election well we had
an election who is the president
it's happened twenty nine years well
you're in an election year's like so you
mean he's not the president until you
know january or whatever it is
of course he is so it's an asylum answer
but again no one's going to call him
out on on that very real fact there are
people watching in america right now
that think oh well because an election
that's different
like you're only partially president
because you're in an election year that
it's ridiculous but by not contesting it
but by not saying well that's not how it
works that's not how the constitution
by the way that's not what obama said
that's not what biden said it's not what
ginsburg said it's not what schumer said
it's not what pelosi said
in 16 with merrick garland the
difference is they didn't control the
senate and they didn't have the votes
how do you feel as we we now see all of
these instances i mean
and it seems to be every swing state we
have issues in pennsylvania we have
issues in north carolina
we have issues in wisconsin um as it
relates to oh let's change the rules
um let's extend out the days in which
we'll we'll
actually count votes well it's a big
problem it's happening in all of the
states that have democrat control right
because that's how they play their games
you know they're
they don't have a ground game they
haven't bothered to try to staff that up
they haven't done door knocking they
don't have to their plan is to start all
of this on november 4th
when they can start just litigating it
contesting it and you know in places
like pennsylvania where you have a
democrat governor and a democrat state
legislator that's why it was so critical
for my father say hey you guys got to
get out there and vote
you know this has to be a landslide if
it's in the margins these guys are going
to play games
ballots are going to be coming in for
weeks and probably months afterwards
they will magically all be a hundred
percent for joe biden because we've seen
how this works we've seen this game play
out too many times
republicans don't win special elections
once they go past
every ballot was cast for your dad that
was in the garbage pants yeah from the
military
you know and again that doesn't mean but
the notion also that absentee balloting
is perfect well this isn't absolutely
balancing mailing
states that have never done this before
doing a dry run
with literally hundreds of millions of
potential ballots that's not the same as
an absentee ballot system like you have
in florida that has worked for years
there are differences but they try to
take and conflate the issues
they try to say oh no well it works in
florida yeah in a system that's been
tried and proven and tested the
democrats don't want the signatures
to have to match up on ballots across
the like please explain to me
give me one reason sean one reason why
the signature of the person who's saying
they're voting who's registered to vote
should not have to match unless you're
trying to steal the elections 2016
when i went to the dnc convention i
needed a photo id
yeah uh and usually i'd go there the
guys who said hi mr hannity well you're
obviously
your id you're obviously racist that's
their answer for everything i mean
it's asinine okay i mean if you can't
figure out how to get an id in this
country it's one of the easiest things
in the world
uh it is the biggest choice election
this country will face i gotta let you
go i appreciate you stopping by thank
you very much elbows out right you are
man i throw them on
yes you know my anyway